ونبدا نشرتنا من تداعيات تفجير سدك خوفك
وينضم الينا من خير سنه مراسل الجزيره
حسان مسعود وهو في هذا القارب في هذه
الشوارع في خرسنه التي غرقت بعد تفجير
فاخبرنا بمشاهداتك وقد وصلت الى هناك
للتوحسان
الان في شوارع مدينه خرسون التي اصابتها
ما وصفها مدير مكتب الرئاسه الاوكرانيه
باكبر كارثه انسانيه من صنع البشر بعد
تفجير سد كخوفك نحن الان في هذه الشوارع
التي كنا نمر بها بيئه السيارات او على
الاقدام الان باتت مغموره بالمياه لا
نستطيع ان نتحرك فيها الا عبر هذه القوارب
التي تشاهدون عبرها هذه الصور الان
المباشره على شاشه الجزيره هذه المشاهد
الان هذه المناطق التي نمر بها هي شوارع
على الاقل عمق المياه هنا اكثر من متر
ونصف ونصف في هذه المنطقه حيث نوجد الان
تشاهدون هذه المباني التي نمر عليها خلفي
ايضا مباشره تستمر عمليات الاجلاء للسكان
بهذه الزوارق كما تشاهدون هذه الزوارق هي
الوسيله الوحيده التي يستخدمها السكان
وتستخدمها ايضا الشرطه الاوكرانيه والجيش
الاوكرانيه والقوات هناك لكي يحاولوا
الوصول الى السكان الذين ما زالوا عالقين
في عدد من المنازل عدد من المباني ايضا
السكنيه في هذه المنطقه نستطيع ان نشاهد
هنا على يمين الشاشه هذه هذا المبنى الذي
غمره
مياه غمرته المياه كما تشاهدون وقد وصلت
الى اعلى مدخل المنزل هذا مؤشر بسيط على
حجم الغرق الذي
ادى هذا الانفجار الى احداثه هنا في هذه
المدينه مدينه خرسون تشاهدون ايضا عمليات
الاجلاء المستمره في مدينه خرسون هذه
المدينه التي تشهد على اضرار كبيره للغايه
في مدينه خرسون نظرا لهذا الانفجار انفجار
السد
حتى هذه اللحظه المعطيات الاوليه تشير الى
ان القوات الاوكرانيه تمكنت من اجلاء اكثر
من 1500 شخص عبر هذه الوسائل البسيطه كما
تشاهدون هذه القوارب التي تتجول في المياه
في ظل ظروف شديده الخطوره نظرا لان يعني
الضفتين
تنقلها ان بالفعل يعني مستوى الماء ليس
منخفضا هو يعني
مستوى عالي الى حد كبير ونشاهده من خلال
الابواب واحد المنازل التي يعني رايناها
وهذه الابواب التي نشاهدها الان في الشاشه
نعم عثمان بالفعل نحن كنا نمر بهذه
الشوارع عندما كنا نغطي احداث المعارك
الجبهه المفتوحه هنا في مدينه خرسون كنا
نمر بهذه الشوارع ما نستطيع قوله ان هنا
ما نشاهده في هذه اللحظات هو عباره عن
مشهد صادم للغايه
المنازل مغموره بالمياه
الطرقات مغموره بالمياه كما تشاهدون اعلى
المنزل هذا هو سقف المنزل كما تشاهد عثمان
وسقف المنزل وصلته هو هذه المياه هنا كما
تشاهدون هذا المشهد غير معتاد ويمكن ان
نتخيل حجم الضرر الذي ادى هذا حتى
عندما نشاهد الصوره حسان عثمان هذا سمحت
لي هذا هذا المبنى الذي مررنا عليه هو
ايضا دينا الان يتعرض للغرق يعني هذا
الامر يجعلنا نفكر عندما يصل مستوى المياه
الى هذه الدرجه لدرجه انه غطى الباب في
المدخل فكيف يخرج الناس
لا يخرج الناس الا بهذه الطريقه التي
تشاهدها على الهواء مباشره عثمان بعبره
استخدام الزوارق المطاطيه من متطوعين من
قوات للجيش من قوات للشرطه الذين اتوا الى
هنا اكثر من 1500 متطوع يعملون في هذه
اللحظات على محاوله انقاذ الناس نشاهد هذه
العائله الان في هذا القارب وهم وهم
يقومون
بالاجلاء بعمليات الاجلاء في هذه اللحظه
يتم اجلؤهم عبر هذه الوسائل فقط عبر هذه
الزوارق المطاطيه وكما ذكرت عثمان لك نعود
لنشاهد هذا المبنى مثلا هذا المنزل غمر
بالكامل عثمان غمر بالكامل كما تشاهدون
هذا المنزل
سطح المبنى القرميذي
غمر بالمياه اكثر من الف منزل حتى هذه
اللحظه على الاقل ووفق المعطيات الاوليه
تم غمره بالمياه كما بهذه الطريقه نشاهد
هذا الكم من الدمار الذي احدثته المياه
اكثر من 1500 شخص تم اجلائهم بالفعل واكثر
من 1200 من السكان قامت السلطات بمحاوله
اجلائهم عبر عدد من الوسائل عبر عدد كبير
اكثر من 1500 متطوع يعملون في هذه الاثناء
لاجلاء عدد كبير من السكان نتوقع ان هناك
17 الف شخص على الاقل وفق المعطيات
الاوليه الرسميه سيتم اجلاؤهم من هنا
باتجاه مناطق اخرى تشاهد هذه المباني
عثمان هذه المباني تظهر لك حجم حجم الدمار
الذي وصل بسبب هذه المياه التي غامرت
المنطقه وكل ما نتحدث عنه الان هو فقط في
الضفه اليمنى لنهر خرسون في الضفه اليمنى
لخرسون نستطيع مشاهده حجم الدمار
وفي ذات الوقت
ان الضفه اليسرى تعرضت لدمار اكبر لغمر
اكبر بالمياه نظرا للطبيعه الجغرافيه نحن
الان
نظهر هذه المشاهد الكاميرا في الخلف ربما
تستطيعون مشاهده العمق الافق وهناك في
الافق هي الضفه اليسرى لنهر دينيبرو تلك
المنطقه غمرتها المياه بشكل اكبر حتى من
الضفه اليمنى ولكن اكثر ما لفت الانتباه
اكثر ما لفت الانتباه عثمان وهذه ملاحظه
للحظات الاولى تمكنا من مشاهدتها هي ان
هذه ان هذه السفن هذه الزوارق الصغيره هذه
القوارب المطاطيه تمكنت من
جلب اشخاص من الضفه اليسرى التي تخضع
لسيطره القوات الروسيه الى الضفه اليمنى
تخيل هذا الغرق ساهم بايصال اعداد من
الاشخاص الذين قابلناهم قبل قليل تمكنوا
من الوصول من الضفه اليسرى التي
تسيطر عليها القوات الروسيه الى الضفه
اليمنى التي تسيطر عليها القوات
الاوكرانيه بفعل هذا الفيضان وعبر هذه
الزوارق هذا يعني ان هذه الزوارق تمكنت من
كسر الحواجز كسر الجبهه التي كان الناس
يعيشون فيها منذ بدايه هذه الحرب خرسون هي
من اول المدن في اوكرانيا التي تمكنت
القوات الروسيه من السيطره عليها كان هناك
معركه كبرى تعتبر كما وتوصف هنا في
اوكرانيا لاستعاده السيطره على مدينه
خرسون اواخر العام الماضي تحديدا خلال شهر
سبتمبر الماضي وبعده خلال اكتوبر ووصل
وصلت القوات الاوكرانيه الى استعاده
السيطره على هذه المدينه مدينه خرسون
عاصمه المقاطعه
بعد استعاده السيطره عليها كان هناك حديث
مطول عن ان الهجوم المضاد يمكن ان يحدث
هنا في مدينه خرسون باتجاه الضفه اليسرى
لكن ما جرى اليوم هذا الحدث الكبير ادى
كما كما ذكرت الى بعض الخروقات التي تمكن
من خلالها عدد من سكان الضفه اليسرى الذين
بالمناسبه تقول السلطات الاوكرانيه ان
السلطات التي تسيطر على الضفه اليسرى من
السلطات الروسيه لم تتمكن من الحصول على
او من انقاذ الناس هناك بشكل المناسب لم
يكونوا مستعدين لمثل هذا السيناريو رغم
الاتهام المباشر من الجانب الاوكراني
للجانب الروسي
بالقيام بهذا الامر وبهذا الحدث قالوا
انهم لم يكونوا مستعدين لذلك لم يتمكنوا
من مساعده وانقاذ الناس وهناك العديد من
الناس الذين ما زالوا عالقين في الضفه
اليسرى للنهر
هنا في الضفه اليمنى الواقع صعب للغايه
وعمليات الانقاذ ما زالت مستمره نشاهد هذه
المشاهد الان التي تظهر حجم الضرر ربما
سيتمكن الزميل المصور مارسيلو ان يظهر لكم
في هذه الاثناء حجم الضرر نشاهد هذا
المبنى وصل وصلت المياه الى الشرفه
الاخيره الى هذا المكان انا اعتقد ان هذا
المبنى على الاقل على الاقل طوله ثلاث
ونصف متر او اربعه امتار ونحن نشاهد ان
هذه المياه وصلت الى منتصف المسافه في هذا
المبنى هذا يعني ان المياه هنا غمرت هذه
المباني بشكل كبير كما تشاهدون والاداره
العسكريه كانت قد حذرت ان القوات
الاوكرانيه تعمل على انقاذ الناس وعلى
انقاذ مزيد من الاشخاص نظرا لان هذا
المكان يمكن ان تزداد فيه وان يرتفع فيه
منسوب المياه لان المياه لم تتوقف عن
التدفق خلال الليل القوات الاوكرانيه تحذر
من ان المياه لم تتوقف عن التدفق الى
الليل ربما ستستطيع ان تشاهد معي الان
عثمان نحن بارتفاع هذه الحبال وهذه
الكابلات الخاصه بالكهرباء لا نستطيع ان
ان نمر دون ان ننخفض وان ننحني ونحن في
هذا القارب تخيل حجم الضرر حجم الدمار
الذي اصاب هذه المدينه تستطيع ان تشاهد ان
هذا المبنى على سبيل المثال ايضا والمبنى
الذي خلف هذا المبنى ايضا هو مبنى متضرر
بفعل القصف هو مزيج هذا الواقع الذي
نشاهده الان في خرسون هو مزيج ما بين
الدمار الذي حدث لمدينه خرسون الاوكرانيه
مثال
بفعل الضرر بفعل هذه المياه التي غمرت
المدينه وفي ذات الوقت هو مزيج بين الضرر
الذي حدث لهذه المدينه بفعل
المياه التي غمرت المدينه وهذا التطور
يعتبر تطورا كبيرا في هذه الحرب يعتبر من
اكبر الاحداث التي حدثت في هذه الحرب
الاوكرانيه الروسيه مدرج
انت يعني تعرف هذه الشوارع جيدا قبل ان
تغمر بالمياه بهذه الطريقه شكرا لك
ولزميلنا المصور ايضا مارسيلو على النقل
الصوره في خرسون الغارقه بالمياه على هذا
[موسيقى]